welcome to the man of recaps this is the
all spider-man's recap leading up to
spider-man no way home travel back in
time with me to 2002 with the original
tobey maguire spider-man trilogy peter
parker is a lovable nerd who one day on
a school field trip visits an advanced
genetic engineering lab for some reason
and this lab's a real amateur operation
because they've let one of their
genetically modified super spiders
escape and it bites peter parker and
peter wakes up with super powers some
great ones like enhanced strength and
agility but his main power is he's
sticky and he can shoot webb out of his
wrists comic nerds will tell you that's
not one of his powers he designed his
web with science skills but they just
streamlined it in this one now
apparently peter's parents died when he
was young though they don't go into it
in this one so he lives with his aunt
may and uncle ben his uncle ben gives
him some iconic advice with great power
comes great responsibility but at first
peter uses his powers irresponsibly
doing the obvious thing and becoming an
amateur wrestler but the guy gypsy iman
is winning so when he gets robbed peter
steps aside and lets the thief escape
but that thief went on to kill his uncle
ben no uncle ben so peter turns his
powers to fighting crime and soon
becomes our friendly neighborhood
spider-man now peter has a crush on mary
jane watson though he's not much of a
ladies man his best friend is the rich
kid harry osborne who goes to talk peter
up but ends up dating mary jane himself
worst wing man ever harry's father is
norman osborne founder of ozcorp and
they're making super soldier serum for
the military but if they don't get to
successful human trials soon they're
gonna shut down their funding so norman
tested on himself and it works but as a
side effect he goes a little crazy he
ends up with a golem from lord of the
rings split personality he becomes the
green goblin flying around on the glider
and throwing his iconic pumpkin bombs he
and spider-man fight a few times but
they are evenly matched in the meantime
peter graduates high school and besides
being a science genius he's also an
amateur photographer because he is
spider-man he's able to get the best
pictures of him and so gets a job at the
daily bugle working for jay jonah
jameson he's a hilarious character and
for no good reason hates spider-man
always twists the facts to make
spider-man look like a menace peter
finally found the courage to talk to
girls and starts flirting with mj and as
spider-man he saved her a few times
she's kind of got a crush on the web
slinger they have their famous upside
down kiss of course she is still dating
harry at this point but it's not
cheating if it's a superhero so
spider-man and the green goblin continue
to face off but at thanksgiving norman
discovers peter's secret and so he goes
after peter's loved ones kidnapping mary
jane they have their final fight and
spider-man wins but then he discovers
his arch nemesis is his best friend's
father and he tries to trick him gonna
kill him with his glider but spider-man
dodges and he stabs himself so
spider-man's first villain winds up dead
and when he brings his body back harry
catches him in the act he now vows
revenge on spider-man for killing his
father meanwhile mj has realized that
she's in love with peter but he knows
his loved ones will always be in danger
so he rejects her with no explanation
destroying her self-confidence and
that's where spider-man 1 comes to an
end next up is spider-man 2 which became
the blueprint for how to make a good
superhero sequel we meet dr otto
octavius who's trying to make a fusion
reaction but the more impressive
invention are the robot arms he's
designed as lab assistants so he's doing
the science thing but it goes wrong and
oh zap fuses the arms to his brain they
got a mind of their own now he also gets
a golem from lord of the rings split
personality and becomes doctor octopus
he and spider-man have some sweet fights
but all these late nights are taking a
toll on peter's personal life with no
time to study he's failing out of
college being a superhero doesn't pay
well so he's always behind on rent j
jonah jameson criminally underpays him
so he gets a second job delivering
pizzas but there's always some dumb kids
that need savings so he fails at that
too he and mj still love each other
though they've agreed to be just friends
she's landed an acting gig but peter's
always busy he never comes so eventually
she moves on starts dating someone else
though he can't really live up to
spider-man but very quickly they get
engaged it's been like a month are you
sure you're not rushing this but hey you
snooze you lose pal so with this
heartbreak peter's powers stop working
but he's like you know it's for the best
i am spider-man no more so life is much
simpler as just peter parker but soon he
gets a pep talk from aunt may who
basically paraphrases with great power
comes great responsibility and even
though they're not dating specifically
to prevent this soon dr octopus kidnaps
mj anyway so peter's powers are back is
spider-man time he and dr octopus have a
big fight on a train but in the end
peter's got to try to stop it oh all the
webs straining so hard he passes out but
the people of new york jesus crowd serve
him and all agree to not reveal his
secret identity but harry osborne still
wants revenge on spider-man and makes a
deal with doctor octopus and he's
surprised to find his arch nemesis is
his best friend peter peter you killed
my father no i am your father anyway
peter goes for the final showdown with
doctor octopus where he grabs the
electric wire and no electrocutes him it
shorts out his evil tentacles so he's
like whoops i've been the bad guy he
sacrifices himself to stop his evil
science thing from destroying the city
and spider-man's two for two his
villains dying during the fight his mask
fell off and mary jane discovered his
identity he's like hey baby i love you
but to keep you safe we can't be
together but she's like yo that's dumb i
keep getting kidnapped anyway and so on
her wedding day she runs off to be with
peter a big romantic gesture but
horribly inconsiderate so peter and mj
finally get together and as spider-man 2
comes to an end crank that volume for
the dashboard confessional credit song
then it's spider-man 3 which became the
blueprint for exactly how not to end a
superhero trilogy life is good for
spider-man but harry osborn has still
not forgiven peter in fact now he starts
talking to his golem ghost dad finds his
green goblin man cave and turns his lame
glider into a cool hoverboard he has a
big fight with his former best friend
but in the end oh harry gets a bump on
the head he wakes up with a little
amnesia conveniently just the stuff that
made him a villain so peter and harry
best friends again things are going
great with mary jane in fact peter's
also planning to rush into an engagement
but at the spider-man celebration to
give the crowd a show he has an upside
down kiss with gwen stacy oh hell nah
peter plans to propose at the fancy
french restaurant but his timing's
horrible they have a big fight then
there's an escaped convict on the loose
but he's kind of a good guy only turned
a crime to pay for his sick daughter's
medical bills we really need free
universal health care while running from
the cops he ends up in an experimental
science place this city has a huge
problem with dangerous experiment safety
protocols so they science his molecules
into a bunch of sand and he becomes the
sand sandman but turns out this guy was
the partner of the thief who shot uncle
ben in fact it was him who shot uncle
ben this news sends peter on the path to
the dark side and conveniently a
meteorite just dropped nearby carrying
an alien black goose symbiote it latches
on to peter's negative emotions and he
wakes up in the black spider-man
symbiote suit he goes down for his
rematch with sandman and he's not
holding back anymore he blasts him with
the water that he thinks will kill him
three for three baby so wearing the
black suits like frodo in the ring or
harry in the horcrux it amplifies his
negative emotions when harry gets his
memory back and starts messing with
peter peter's not playing around blows
him up and so peter is loving that dark
side life and it is the famous street
dancing montage one of the greatest
scenes ever put to film in the end he
takes gwen stacy on a date to the jazz
club where mary jane works and upstages
her solo with an absurd dance routine
but in the end he accidentally hurts
mary jane revenge of the sith style and
realizes he's become a villain unlike
anakin he decides to turn away from the
dark side but taking off the symbiote
suits harder than it seems conveniently
though there's another angry man nearby
it's eddie brock he's a photographer
that was trying to take peter's job so
darkseid peter got him fired and
accidentally stole his girlfriend so now
the goo latches on to his hatred of
peter and he becomes venom but a weirdly
wimpy lame version of venom who's only
in the movie for the last 10 minutes and
so to stop him peter's got to put back
on his classic red and blue spidey suit
but sand man survived he and venom team
up and spider-man can't take both of
them but who's flying in to even the
odds it's harry osborn who for some
reason has forgiven peter so it's a best
bro team-up they easily take down
sandman but now venom's leaping in with
the flying razor scooter so harry ow
sacrifices himself to save his friend
stabbed by his own scooter just like his
father now it's never really explained
but the symbiote doesn't like loud
noises and so peter smacks all the poles
around it pulls eddie brock out of there
goes to blow it up but eddie likes being
venom he jumps back into it and how is
exploded another villain accidentally
murdered by spider-man sandman decides
to beat the odds and peace out of there
peter goes back to mary jane's jazz club
even though he should probably be banned
for life they don't say anything but
there's an implied apology and that's
where spider-man 3 comes to an end then
just a few short years later it's
already time for a reboot it's the
amazing spider-man andrew garfield plays
kind of a cool skater boy peter parker
he lives with his aunt may and uncle ben
but this time his parents death is a big
part of the plot they were scientists
doing genetic research on spiders but
they had to mysteriously leave one night
and were assassinated by oscorp so
investigating his parents death peter
sneaks into the restricted area at
oscorp which is a much more logical
place to find genetically modified
spiders instead of out in the open at a
school field trip but you know how it
goes one of the spiders bites him and he
wakes up with sticky powers but this
time he can't shoot webs they stay true
to the comics he sciences his own web
shooters one night his uncle ben
basically paraphrases with great power
comes great responsibility but the
convenience store clerk is kind of a
dick so when he gets robbed peter
doesn't stop him and that thief goes on
to shoot his uncle ben now uncle ben so
now peter uses his powers to fight crime
and becomes the amazing spider-man
although he's not much of a hero at
first he's a vigilante bent on revenge
looking specifically for the guy that
killed his uncle and so spider-man's
being hunted by the police especially
captain stacy father of peter's crush
gwen stacy she's also a super smart
science nerd and depending on who you
ask their interactions are endearingly
awkward or painfully awkward but as two
awkward science nerds who also happen to
both be gorgeous they were meant for
each other and soon get together and he
doesn't keep it a secret this time she
knows he's spider-man now peter's
parents had a colleague at ozcorp dr
kirk connors who's missing an arm and
hopes to grow it back by crossing
himself with a lizard but he can't get
the science to work it was only peter's
father who figured out the formula but
now peter shares it with him and this
looks very promising but oscorp wants a
successful human trial now or they'll
pull his funding so dr connor's tested
on himself and it works he grows an arm
back but there are some side effects and
soon he becomes the lizard he and
spider-man face off a few times
including a cool fight scene at the high
school but now he's become fully
deranged his master plan is to turn
everyone into lizards spider-man's gotta
stop him but he's too far away luckily
all new yorkers stick together the
construction crews all line up the
cranes so spider-man can swing on in he
and the lizard have their final fight
and spider-man boom gets the antidote in
and stops the evil plan dr connor's
turned back into a human but he doesn't
die this time he goes to prison where he
receives a mysterious visitor a guy with
a hat but earlier captain stacy
discovered spider-man's his daughter's
boyfriend he came to help fight the
lizard but oh got himself killed he has
peter make him a dying promise don't
date my daughter that'll put her in
danger he tries to break up with gwen
but she's like yo that's dumb and so
these two stay together next up is the
amazing spider-man 2. life is good for
spider-man as he graduates high school
and is definitely still dating when
stacey but now he feels guilty about
breaking his promise again and gwen's
like yo i can't have this rollercoaster
we break up he spends the rest of the
movie creepily stalking her until she's
about to leave for an internship he webs
her a message and they're back together
now meet max an electrical engineer with
no friends who spider-man saves one day
and after that becomes a little too much
of a fanboy he works at ozcorp which is
impractically powered by genetically
engineered electric eels one night
there's a gross violation of workplace
safety laws and he falls down into the
tank bitten by the eels and turns into
electro now max hasn't hurt anyone yet
his only crime is being a blue man in a
hoodie but the police open fire and
escalate the situation he starts zapping
things with a cool dubstep soundtrack
eventually though spider-man hits him
with the fire hose which puts him out
for now now it's time to meet this
version of harry osborne whose father
norman osborne just dies of a genetic
disease in fact curing that disease is
his motivation for all this genetic
research in the first place now because
the parents work together harry and
peter are childhood friends harry
figures out that spider-man must be a
success case of their parents research
and he wants to do it on himself but
this prompts peter to research his
parents again which leads him to
platform nine and three quarters his dad
had a secret lab and a subway car there
and left him a message turns out he made
the super spiders with his own dna which
is why it only worked on peter they're
genetically related so he visits harry
has spider-man hey sorry bro but it's
not gonna work on you but harry doesn't
take it well he makes a deal with
electro to set him free in exchange for
blast in the board and get hairy access
to the spider venom and now elektra's on
the loose again he and spider-man have
another dubstep fight when stacy's here
to help she does the science thing to
zap electro with too much power and
explodes him but now harry with the
spider venom as anticipated has some bad
side effects he crawls his way to the
prototype glider and now flies in as the
green goblin oh looking real ugly as he
and spider-man have their super fight
gwen is precariously close by in fact at
the end she falls down but oh spider-man
manages to grab her but she's not out of
danger yet and eventually the web snaps
she starts falling spider-man dives
after her and this situation happens
basically every movie it always works
out but this time when he webs her he
was just too late oh she hits the ground
that's not supposed to happen he's
supposed to save her i'm not here to
feel sad and so peter parker is
devastated he gives up being spider-man
for a while but in prison harry osborn
has a meeting with the mysterious hat
man who's trying to recruit a bunch of
villains to be the sinister six first he
releases the rhino and the world needs
spider-man to save him it may gives him
a pep talk which basically paraphrases
with great power comes great
responsibility and so spider-man comes
out of retirement to fight the rhino and
that's where the amazing spider-man 2
comes to an end and we never get an
amazing spider-man 3 because just two
years later it's time for spider-man to
come home and finally join the marvel
cinematic universe he first appears in
captain america civil war with tom
holland playing an adorkably cute peter
parker and they make a great choice here
to skip right over his origin story we
know how it goes radioactive spider
uncle ben great power great
responsibility his fellow science genius
tony stark iron man who recruits peter
onto his side of the superhero civil war
then he gets his own movie in the mcu
it's spider-man homecoming after the
adventure of civil war peter wants to be
an avenger but mr stark's like hey
you're not ready yet kid so for now
peter does small time hero stuff around
queens becoming a friendly neighborhood
spider-man one night though he foils a
robbery from some guys that have very
dangerous alien tech they bought it from
a guy with cool wingsuit it's the
vulture who scavenges advanced weaponry
and sells it on the black market but
he's not some hardcore villain his
vibe's just a blue collar worker trying
to provide for his family so peter calls
his point man happy hogan tony stark's
longtime driver and friend but he's like
hey kid that sounds dangerous don't get
involved so for now peter's life
continues as normal he's got a best
friend ned who soon discovers he's
spider-man and joins team spider helps
peter hack the fancy new suit tony stark
gave him and turn off the training
wheels program this opens up a ton of
new features including instant kill mode
watch out for that they go on a field
trip to washington dc where spider-man's
got to climb the washington monument to
save his classmates including his crush
liz but back in new york spider-man
tries to disrupt an arms deal on the
staten island ferry where the vulture
busts in with a big alien gun and oh the
whole boat gets blown apart spider-man's
got to hold it together but he can't
this time in fact it's iron man who
flies in to save the day tony stark is
real mad now i told you it was too
dangerous kid i'm taking my fancy suit
back so peter focuses on his normal life
where he asks his crush liz to the
homecoming dance but turns out liz's
father is the vulture and turns out
tonight he's gonna pull one last job
because the avengers tower is
transporting all of their advanced
technology so without his fancy super
suit peter puts on his old-fashioned
homemade sweatshirt outfit he and
vulture have a big fight on the plane
and end up crashing the whole thing
vulture's gonna get away but his
wingsuit malfunctions and he falls into
the fire but this spider-man's not gonna
let him die he rushes in there and
forrest gumps him to safety he does go
to jail but because spider-man saved his
life he doesn't reveal his secret
identity so now tony stark's like
congrats kid you proved yourself you can
be a full avenger but he's like you know
i think you were right i'm not ready for
the big leagues yet i'll see you after
high school but he's immediately thrust
into the big leagues with avengers
infinity war it's in new york where
thanos ship first arrives so
spider-man's nearby to help out he ends
up on the ship but can not breathe in
space lucky tony stark's got a gift for
him it's the new iron spider suit it
comes with some extra legs that are
pretty helpful it's here that peter
first meets doctor strange who looks
like will play a big part in no way home
long story short he's a wizard now
obviously spoiler warning for infinity
war but at the end of course the
avengers lose thanos snaps away half the
population including peter parker it's a
heart-wrenching scene i don't feel so
good mr stark as peter's dusted away
leaving tony feeling guilty but then in
avengers end game obviously spoiler
warning again the avengers managed to
bring back everyone who was lost
including our spider-man who joins in
the final battle and finally activates
instant kill mode but in the end tony
stark has to sacrifice himself to defeat
thanos and save the universe and that
brings us to spider-man far from home
it's the first marvel movie after end
game where we get to see the results of
half the population being snapped away
then five years later being snapped back
to the same place the world calls this
the blip and it's caused a lot of issues
but tony stark's death weighs heavy on
peter the world's looking to him to
leave the avengers now but he's not
ready he just wants to be a normal
teenager this summer enjoying his
school's european field trip and hoping
to ask out his new crush mj she has a
real deadpan sort of dark humor and is
hilarious but their trip is interrupted
when a giant water monster attacks
venice peter springs into action but
there's another superhero here a new guy
named mysterio who flies around shooting
lasers makes short work of this thing
that knight peter's picked up by nick
fury who brings him in on the mission
turns out mysterio is quentin beck a
real great hero from a parallel earth
his earth was destroyed by these
elementals and now he's traveled here to
help save this one and so nick fury
hijacks peter's field trip to get him to
prague to fight the fire monster they
he'll come up with a new tactical black
suit though so people don't recognize
spider-man in europe it's ned who comes
up with the cover story no this guy's a
european knockoff named night monkey
anyway mysterio defeats this fire
monster really didn't need spider-man's
help he and peter gets talking it's like
hey man i don't want all this pressure
yet i just want to be a teenager in fact
peter has some more big pressure on him
because tony stark left him a pair of
glasses they give him access to edith
the entire arsenal of stark tech and he
almost drone strikes his own bus so now
peter's like hey that's too much
responsibility for me i'm just a kid i
can't be the next tony stark yet but you
mysterio have proven yourself to be a
great guy you take the glasses and be
the next iron man so a weight has lifted
off peter's shoulders but wait what's
this the whole bar was a hologram this
was all a con to get edith from peter
yeah this crew is a bunch of disgruntled
former stark employees quentin back
designed this advanced holographic
technology but stark didn't like it and
fired him so now they're using this
illusion tech to create mysterio and
become the world's next big superhero
it's not all fake though there's
weaponized drones so the damage is real
but for now peter's hanging out with mj
he's about to confess his feelings for
her but she thinks he's about to confess
that he's spider-man yeah she figured it
out but she happened to pick up a piece
of drone that got hit and when it
activates peter realizes it was all fake
he was conned he tries to warn nick fury
but mysterio's already here and it's
impossible to fight him when you don't
know what's real spider-man survives
though and he calls happy for a ride
happy has started hanging around more
often because this time peter has a hot
ant-may he's got a huge crush on her but
for now peter's feeling real down and it
could be a time for a great power great
responsibility pep talk but actually
happy gives him a much better one where
it's like hey you've got iron man on
this pedestal but tony was a hot mess
who had no idea what he was doing most
of the time so peter gets to work
designs himself a new suit and at
mysterio's grand finale he busts in
there inside the illusion to tear it
apart but he still has to fight an army
of drones and eventually mysterio
himself who puts him back in illusion
land now one of spider-man's powers has
always been the spider sense where he
can sense danger coming in this movie
ant may hilariously dubs it the peter
tingle but now he turns that tingle on
closes his eyes use the force luke and
oh he's able to see right through these
illusions mr hiro gets hit by his own
drones and it looks like peter won but
oh it was another double fake out
luckily peter saw through at this time
but i guess quentin did actually get hit
because it seems like he dies so the day
is saved peter and mj have their
hilarious realistically awkward first
kiss nick fury's like good job
spider-man but turns out that's not nick
fury they're scroll shape-shifters
they're good guys though covering for
fury while he's off on a mission and
turns out that mission is out in space
so watch out for that so it's a happy
ending until there's a breaking news
story from the daily bugle with j jonah
jameson yes he's back turns out
mysterio's team leaked a recording where
they altered the audio to make
spider-man look like the villain and on
top of that he now out spider-man's
secret identity tells the world he's
peter parker and that brings us up to
speed for spider-man no way home
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and movies and if you loved
this recap check out the join button and
support the channel as a member